la población de mico life donde nos
encontramos se ha convertido en un lugar
estratégico desde el comienzo de la
guerra es una población donde se unen
las tropas que vienen desde el mar de
azov hacia el mar negro está a más o
menos 50 kilómetros de que el sol hoy en
poder de las tropas rusas y a 130
kilómetros de la ciudad donde es a estar
en este punto estratégico ha hecho que
la vida de la población cambie
radicalmente en estas últimas semanas y
meses más de la mitad de los 500.000
habitantes se han marchado y quienes se
han quedado tienen que vivir situaciones
como estas por ejemplo aquí vienen
cientos de personas cada día a tomar
agua en bidones desde que hace tres
semanas las fuerzas rusas explotaron
todas las tuberías que traían el agua
desde que son pero esto no es lo único
que ha cambiado en la vida especialmente
les preocupa la seguridad cada vez que
llega la noche entre 8 y 9 llegan los
toques de queda todas las luces de la
ciudad se apagan la gente se mete en sus
casas y en pie generalmente los
bombardeos y es que lo que más les
preocupa es que sigue siendo un lugar
estratégico para las fuerzas rusas que
siguen diciendo que una de sus
intenciones es tomar toda la costa de
ucrania